per la a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti ha
messo poi mica quanto va devo tirare
questa roba non però le palle fino alla
fine dei tempi solo per sta roba bella
ex ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente ed oggi sia il nuovo
blog prima di parlarvi di questa roba di
ip di pike e ve la devo ovviamente
spiegare passiamo a quello l'argomento
per il quale avete cliccato dalla
copertina del video perché questo non è
un tweet based dello schifo è vero
purtroppo eravamo a catania raduno a
catania che abbiamo fattori come ad ogni
raduno ai fan ci portano delle cose ci
portano e dei regali insomma dentro uno
di questi pacchi regalo c'era questa
cosa qua tutto per voi
ok racca siamo nel backstage dell'evento
che abbiamo fatto a catania e abbiamo de
scatolato un bel po di regali
io ho de scatolato un mio regalo e se vi
faccio vedere che cosa mi hanno regalato
perché io non lo posso tenere però c'è
salvo che entra e via vieni salvo e ci
fai qui vandelli cosa musica dell'impero
dai che mi mettono è copyright
allora praticamente mai cioè mi hanno
regalato si fa propri i valori stante
questa metta a 7 euro con la copertina
del video fai vedere che ci sono i
periti cessi veliche vero salto degli
starnuti sapiente risaltare salvo pezzo
di merda allora mi hanno regalato un
ragno rosso cazzo della aspettare che
devo fare la copertura il video assicura
anche gli occhi chiudi gli occhi di cui
i mandati tale ultimo da un male lo
schermo più di giochi più di giochi
contro vento in faccia tra te e il
sottovento copertina basta promettere
che è vero non araya d'anni fa schifo
siete rientro in bagno a tale tengo il
telefono fuori entrò in bagno così lo
stimo così guarda uscite recco si vedono
le chele zande allora guardate i peletti
se to zoom e abbastanza questo mi fa
schifo possiamo ora anche di servizio un
anno
[Risate]
bastava fatto tantissimo potete andare
via
grazie bene bello minori devo fare come
in alto
devo devo scappare attraverso concessi
effetto ragazzi allora adesso vi spiego
un attimino questa roba perché io faccio
sempre vedere che questa fobia degli
insetti però non ho mai spiegata bene
molti su internet pensano che questa sia
una presa per il culo nel senso ma
fallisce ifaf in carica non c'è paura
dice chi lo fa per me la devo schierare
sta roba ragazzi perché no non è così
vorrei che fosse così quanto vorrei fare
finta di aver paura degli insetti però
non è così io sfrutto questa cosa come
sapendo che alla gente piace vedere che
io urlo come una [ __ ] però è una cosa
che anche agli horror non ci giocherei
di mio perché che mica sono scemo
lo faccio perché so che mi pioli infarti
alla gente questo piace perché siete
tutti i sadici e tutti i sadici
quindi il mio lavoro in realtà non è
quello di farlo e giù per me quello di
soddisfare i sadici quindi quando c'è un
mi sento schifoso in casa se vedete
quando riprendono e che mi avvicino
tanto per fare i close up sta mica
l'insetto lo faccio da un chilometro e
mezzo la mia fobia degli insetti non f
ve lo posso assicurare è vera finché lo
guardo attraverso un monitor è un conto
quando si tratta di un insetto vero è
un'altra
la cosa che vi chiedo di non non
regalarmi ma è roba del genere quanti
siete raduni perché il fatto che io vedo
un insetto da vicino un insetto di quel
genere mi provoca un mini mini
tachicardia non so come dirvelo perché
io soffro veramente di sta roba cioè non
è una cosa finta infatti quando mi hanno
regalato qualcosa era talmente grosso
per assurdo mi faceva meno effetto
perché era talmente grosso che non
sembravano set sembrava un chihuahua
la donna soffriva di meno come roba però
se io vedo l'insetto robe del genere
proprio sto male cioè non è una roba che
faccio per finta quindi non mi regalate
insetti e raduni questo è un discorso
serio poi essere riuscita a trasformare
questa cosa brutta in click pate per
fare views è un'altra roba
però se a voi piace vedermi chemical
addosso quelle due tre volte che è
successo va bene va bene un cazzo prova
passiamo altre ragazze andiamo a
spiegarmi il fatto di più di flight wi
fi in una sua livestream quindi in un
suo video live ha detto bella a tutti i
ragazzi e che io ho dovuto registrare
questa roba marghera etica vita pd
perche pala mentre è assurdo sono
rimasto scioccato quando ho visto sarò
fa sono rimasto veramente scioccato e
quindi da lì mi è venuto in mente di
fare il video di ieri è uscito ieri sera
se non l'avete visto lasciarli ti
descrizione dove faccio la reaction a
più di bike e balla mia intro vi lascio
al backstage del video che fa che ha
fatto anche un backstage di stone mini
video di 28 secondi
buona visione tutte le lingue in ufficio
faccio fare le cose belle si accontenta
di rifare questa felice perfetto volevi
far la tua antonio uil servi del buon
vino in modo sexy in bocca grazie
tieni vaio contente siete con un
miliardario vai
in maniera piena del signore piero lei
piano tiro è venuta bene
sì sì sì poi dopo un po che mela versi
dell'arda prendo esatto non uscite dall
inquadratura sennò mi perdo è la crisi
manca tanto attimo il backstage e voglio
brussa bello questo video anche se
compleanno sistema non è come sembra un
video è ridotto bene io ti ho voluto
bene veramente stock rosa si fa schifo
il vino dovuto bere per far scena di
philippe gilbert basta lavorazione
ragazze e ragazzi grazie che siete state
motivo la ringrazio anche l'arrivo
anteriore comunque sì mi fa veramente
schifo vino il vino e siccome non mi che
non è cresciuta la barba quindi non sono
cresciuto io sono come i bambini
avellino fa veramente schifo mi fanno
proprio vomitare non bevete il vino non
bevete non bevete che poi lo vince
istiga all'alcolismo fa finta con gli
scetti il cig all'alcolismo con gli
insetti
ragazzi miei io credo che il video di
oggi spero che vi sia piaciuto io
comunque vi lascio con una clip finale
visto che ieri mentre abbiamo registrato
sta roba di pilibhit già che c'ero
abbiamo registrato uno shoot out per
social face che vi lascio con i
ragazzini spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa
mi piace anche vari social che come mi
vedo tutto nella schizzare dal city che
ci vediamo il prossimo video ragazzi
negato addosso ciao ragazzi siamo qua
perché io sono solo
niente comunque
mi fai parlare con i ragazzi volevo dire
che sta per tornare il desktop di social
day ci sono tanti sentivo in beige
bocciarlo e poi stiamo facendo delle
foto non mi sento neanche osservato
tanto
basta guardarmi
[Musica]